what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with she-hulk episode 2 easter
eggs breakdowns all the stuff you missed
and i still love this show i think this
show is still hilarious i love the legal
comedy aspect of it right i think it's
just it's great i i think we're being a
little too comedic with the mcu and i'm
kind of i'm kind of looking to get back
to when things are just kind of serious
you know what i mean but i do love the
show i'm having a great time watching it
and there's just these funny moments
right so of course this episode's going
to have spoilers or this video is gonna
have spoilers different things like that
but one of the funny things about this
is is she-hulk basically gets sacked by
the da's office because her turning into
the she-hulk while it does save lives it
results in them basically having the
case thrown out right it's a mistrial
and so as a result of that she's just
kind of like she's job hunting which is
sort of the basis behind this episode
like trying to find a new job you do get
a really cool moment where she
effectively is hired on but one of the
funny things that happens here is
there's a moment where she's talking
with her friend and asking about like
the avengers right whether or not they
offer things like pension and pay and
all that kind of stuff normal employee
benefits now a lot of people are
chalking this little bit of an easter
egg up to like the money problems that
sam wilson had i don't think it is i
think it's actually a reference to
avengers disassembled and the reason why
is because in that story in the comics
that story was actually the lead up to
really like house of m the scholar witch
going crazy and altering reality but the
avengers disassembled for a variety of
reasons right thor was out of the
picture due to the fact that he died or
was dying in ragnarok that whole
situation was going on but for the
avengers themselves they effectively
disbanded because tony stark had been
bankrolling the team for years right he
was the guy who was paying for the
avengers to exist their base of
operations all their health care
everything right he was covering all
that kind of stuff there came a point in
the story when the scarlet witch had
manipulated reality specifically tony
stark to make him appear drunk in front
of the united nations this caused the
stock value of stark industries to
absolutely plummet because the world's
perception was the stark had relapsed
right this stark had fallen back into
alcoholism which is kind of a throwback
to the old demon in a bottle storyline
where seemingly his alcoholism had
gotten the better of him and so because
of that he couldn't afford to pay for
the avengers anymore and they ultimately
disbanded right so it's kind of a
reference to that of course in the mcu
this is more based on the idea that like
tony stark is dead and so because tony
stark has passed away there doesn't seem
to be a provision within stark
industries or what would pass for stark
industries now that pepper potts is most
likely running it that would lead to a
continued funding of the avengers we
don't specifically know if that's the
case and honestly i think that'll be
answered once we get to what would
effectively be like the new avengers in
the mcu which is undoubtedly coming
although i'm surprised they're just
calling it avengers dynasty or king
dynasty and avengers secret wars but
regardless here one of the other big
things that happens and this is kind of
the big easter egg and the talking point
that everybody is addressing here is
that there comes a point when jennifer
walters is basically job hunting she's
surfing the web with her friend and on
this browser page that she's looking at
there are a ton of easter eggs all kinds
of easter eggs and it's kind of funny
because it's sort of the mcu's way of
addressing some of the questions that
we've been asking and even the show does
that to a degree but it's a way to
address a lot of the questions that
we've been asking as the fan base in
terms of what's going on with the
greater mcu because they simply haven't
addressed it yet right so there are
things like like find ant-man right
stuff like that i think you could talk
about the avengers north
norse mythology there's an ad for the
iron man 3 sneakers which i'm not even
gonna lie i kind of hope like marvel and
disney actually release those if they do
they'll sell out in an instant so i'm
really hoping i get my hands on some and
because if i don't they're going to hit
ebay for like 5 000 bucks a piece and
people are going to buy them i'll
probably one of the people who are
stupid enough to do so but at the end of
the day
i have a hard time believing i'll pay
five grand for shoes but you know that's
just the way it goes at the end of the
day it is cool one of the headlines
reads man fights with metal claws in a
barbra now this is a cool thing because
it's one of the things that we saw when
it came to the initial introduction of
wolverine as like a movie character
right just in general in the old fox
x-men movies remember like he was in
like a barbra when he was discovered by
rogue out there in the canadian
wilderness he was basically in a fight
club right fighting in like like cage
matches and so it was cool to see
there's a funny reference to that right
it's a really cool reference to that but
bigger than that what it sounds like is
what i and a lot of people have been
saying this whole time which is the
x-men have been here the entire time now
if you want to know my theory about the
x-men regarding like how mutants exist
in the mcu i do have a video on that
make sure you guys go check that out i
basically create this argument that not
only have x-men been here the entire
time or at least mutants have been here
the entire time in the mcu they're
actually a branch off of the deviants
from the eternals but it's one of those
cool things right it's one of the things
i absolutely love on that same page
there's actually a sidebar headline that
talks about the giant statue from
eternals right like tiamat the dreaming
celestial who's just half sitting out of
the like literally like the ocean is a
bathtub right he's just half sitting in
it and so it's one of those cool things
because that's never been addressed now
i think there are probably better ways
to address this than anything else it's
not like tiamou could only be seen by a
handful of people and so it's like
tabloid magazines in the men in black
movie where they're actually preaching
truth but nobody believes it you know
what i mean like that kind of a thing
like anybody can go there honestly i
think it'd be a hilarious thing if in
the mcu name of the submariner and the
atlanteans are living in timu right like
how you have like little statues and
stuff and like a fish tank that's
basically what's what timu is and like
the ocean for like the atlanteans they
just took up squatters rights inside of
a dead celestial and they've been living
there for a while now
i think that'd be hilarious but it is
cool to see that right it is cool to see
that they are at least referencing that
and honestly it kind of astounds me that
they're doing it in kind of a throwaway
moment that you would actually have to
look for as opposed to like a sort of
broad-based thing where it's like a news
article that happens right i mean this
would have been the perfect time to do
it right it would have been a perfect
time to do it at the you know when they
were doing like those little news
segments opening the show and people are
still wondering what's going on with the
giant statue sticking out of the ocean
right it's just one of those things
where i think the mcu is kind of playing
it back and forth they're playing it
sort of
careful with the eternals like they may
not necessarily keep it all in
continuity right they might just kind of
shuffle it off hope people kind of
forget about it and that's basically it
but again i i doubt that's the case
right the eternals film regardless of
the fact that it basically sucked was an
exceedingly important film because of
like the standard that it set the idea
of invoking like the familiar relations
with like thanos eros being an eternal
who's kind of the adopted brother of
thanos things like that it has it has
its fingers that kind of stretch out
into everything so they can't really get
rid of it per se but again i feel like
they could have done a little bit more
over this time than just sort of making
it a kind of thing that exists out there
now as for the company glk and h that
company does exist in the comics and it
was actually established during dan's
slot she-hulk run back in 2004. the guy
holden holloway the one who approached
she-hulk in the tv show he exists in the
comics as well but there are differences
between the comics and how things unfold
here in the show a really good example
is that in the tv show holden holloway
wanted to bring in she-hulk as the
she-hulk and he wanted her to lead the
superhuman division in the comics it
wasn't that way he thought that she hulk
was a little too reckless too much
flight of fantasy he wanted the actual
jennifer walters who was the
ridiculously skilled lawyer so you
didn't really see that play out in the
show the other motivation behind this is
that instead of using glk and h as a way
to basically launch a superhuman
division and effectively bolster their
pocketbooks right because superheroes
are gonna need legal representation in
the comics the daughter of holden
holloway ended up becoming a villain
named southpaw and in order to ensure
she could be adequately represented that
the entire superhuman law division was
established by holloway and and she hulk
was hired on to lead that division in
order to ensure that southpaw that his
daughter sasha would basically be
represented to the best of anybody's
ability because no one really knew how
to represent superheroes now the bigger
takeaway from this and the reason why
this easter egg is so important is
because this potentially leads into the
introduction of groups like landau
luckman and lake now for people who are
really familiar with marvel comics and
when i say really familiar i mean like
you know your stuff right like you're on
like my level or more knowledgeable when
it comes to comics you know exactly who
landau luckman lake is if you don't know
anything about comics here's who they
are this is an organization that has
their hands at everything they they
pitch themselves in a variety of
different ways but the reality is that
they are just this super clandestine
organization that seeks to guide the
path of humanity into whatever future
that may hold but the way in which they
do this is through a series of like
holding companies some of which are
legal companies right like the the
landau liquid and lake law firm some of
them are are companies that basically
use individuals as agents either
wittingly or unwittingly people like
captain america for example have been
agents of landau lekman and lake albeit
he didn't necessarily know wolverine is
the most most popular example of that
and in fact landau lekman and lake and
their relationship with wolverine is so
strong that they actually hold a lot of
the personal belongings of wolverine
should it become a situation where he
can't have a normal life for himself
right like there's nowhere for him to
put them he's been an agent for them on
a multitude of occasions in fact during
chris claremont's run back in the 80s
there were a lot of stories that dealt
with wolverine and landau luckman and
lake now whether or not we're actually
going to see that play out in the mcu
i'm not entirely sure it's way too early
to know if that's the case or not but it
would be cool to see some kind of
intergalactic holding company that
offers itself as a kind of counter or
maybe something akin to like a competing
law firm in the united states or on
earth and it's just landau luckman and
lake that'd be awesome if you see that
you know exactly what that means what
that means is you're likely going to see
wolverine involved with them right
that's going to be a cool thing like for
example if the mcu really wanted to
bring in that group in that instance
where you have the easter egg where it
talks about the guy with three claws
right with metal claws who gets in a bar
fight that he's basically apprehended by
authorities by whatever man or whatever
means presumably damage control and that
he's being represented by landau lekman
and lake so that'd be cool it'd be
interesting to see if that were going to
happen because wolverine's so popular it
would likely be he'd be represented by
she-hulk but i got to tell you right now
i have a hard time believing that
wolverine will make his debut in the
marvel cinematic universe in the
she-hulk show i just don't see that
happening
it might it might right never say never
i just don't see that happening but the
other cool thing is that you actually
have jennifer walters who of course
calls bruce banner about emilia blonsky
and we all knew that was going to happen
we all knew that conversation was going
to take place somewhere along the line
whether it was before she took the case
while she had the case or after she took
the case and the whole thing was done we
knew that conversation was going to
unfold i did love the entire exchange
between she-hulk and emil blonsky i
absolutely loved it i loved it like he's
turned over a new leaf of course she
holds reference to uh silence of the
lambs was really funny right you know
like is he going to serve me you know
sort of a nice candy and yada yada i
love that whole thing that was that was
a funny little moment but i love the
whole exchange between the two right
emil blonsky like writing haikus trying
to read them and she-hulk just being
like no no no no i'm not i don't want to
hear that i loved that
[Laughter]
it's interesting to see emil blonsky
turning over a new leaf that way but i
felt like this exchange and the
conversation with bruce banner was more
important than people initially gave it
credit for that while it was funny and
while it did have some interesting
interactions the reality for the rally
about this is that it basically
consolidates everything that went on
with the original edward norton
incredible hulk film and they've kind of
done that to a degree right like
thunderbolt ross showing up at the mcu
proper after that original incredible
hulk film people were kind of wondering
where that film resides in continuity is
it even in continuity at all right the
fact that thunderbolt ross had shown up
essentially established that the idea
that uh that bruce banner had initially
turned down the offer to join the
avengers because he quote unquote broke
harlem that was a reference to the
incredible hulk film so we got these
little references here and there and as
time has gone on we know that movie is
actually in continuity and one of the
cool things of course you get a
reference from banners saying like well
i was a different man during that point
in time literally which obviously is a
reference to the fact that edward norton
had played bruce banner before mark
ruffalo had come along but i did love
that whole thing with blonsky right like
he looks like he legitimately is trying
to be a good guy it looks like he
legitimately is trying to turn over a
new leaf now whether or not that bodes
well for him by the fact that he has
essentially escaped with wong
and that he that it shows him in the
cage match during the shang chi film i
don't know how well that's going to go
for him but i do love that whole
situation with uh with emil blonsky i
love what they're doing with this
character now one of the cool things
here is that whole scene with emil
blonsky where it shows that he's escaped
and that he's in the cage match you know
when that took place during shang chi
that tells us exactly where the tv show
resides and it happens alongside shang
chi and that's why i say this whole
situation with emil blonsky in the third
act of this episode is incredibly
important because what this establishes
if it hasn't established it already is
that the marvel cinematic universe is
heavily playing the comic book game in
terms of how they release their films
and tv shows it wasn't like that in the
first 10 years of the mcu with the
exception of maybe one or two movies if
that it all followed a linear chronology
it all followed a straightforward
chronology and if things were out of
continuity meaning that the the newest
movie was not directly after or taking
place during the previous movie that
they would tell us in that movie with
the tv shows it's a little murky
sometimes because what they're doing now
is they're releasing the movies and the
tv shows the same way marvel comics
releases their comic books the same way
they publish their comics so the best
way to follow the marvel cinematic
universe right now is to treat it as
though it's a movie version of a marvel
comics publishing initiative right
they're releasing their movies and tv
shows the same way marvel comics
releases their comic books tie-ins and
main events things like that so you can
largely look at all the movies that we
get right everything after the events of
infinity war and avengers inn game
running all the way up to avengers
secret wars and the kane dynasty and all
that kind of stuff you can treat that as
quote unquote the main story arc and
then the tv shows are the tie-in comics
they fill in the gaps in between and let
us know what's taking place between the
main events that are taking place in the
films in the mcu it's the easiest way to
approach it and it's the best way to
make it make the most sense but it is an
important thing and it is a cool moment
that we get to see there with all that
stuff kind of being reconciled and being
explained now that's kind of the cool
thing is because again we also find out
that the incredible hulk is effectively
going to the car right so that'll likely
pick up with planet hulk a lot of people
have been saying that's what's going to
happen that the marvel cinematic
universe is building up to a proper
planet hulk and world war hulk event
again as far as i'm aware the only thing
that's come out about that is they're
just kind of kicking the idea around
generally and that's essentially it but
they haven't really established anything
etched in stone i don't know exactly how
this is going to unfold i think that the
rumors that are circulating around out
there is that planet hulk and world war
hulk will basically be a tv series other
rumors are saying it's going to actually
be a film but you know as far as that
goes it's just kind of speculation i'm
not really sure but again overall i love
the show right they were just funny
little meta commentary things right you
know like for example when jennifer
walters was talking to her friend about
how she's a little frustrated because
there's more to her than she-hulk it's
kind of like i mean is there though
because you were basically like every
white girl ever on the face of the
planet if i stuck you in a room with 500
other white chicks there's nothing about
you that would stand out but you're the
she-hulk now right it's like the thing
about you that makes you unique
outside of that you're just a white
chick who was a lawyer and that's it
there's like a million of those either
that or like a journalist so it's one of
those things where like i love that the
that whole situation where it's her just
kind of having a hard time leaning into
the thing that makes her unique honestly
i think it's because it just sort of
takes her away from everything she's
known because her life is forever like
it's irrevocably altered there's no
going back there's no unringing this
bell there's no going back to a time
when she's just jennifer walters that
was literally the whole first episode
what she wanted more than anything was
to go back to the life that she had
before even though it was wildly mundane
the fact is like with her being she-hulk
now her life is infinitely more
interesting it's more dangerous but it's
also more interesting than it ever was
before and what this does is it's it
really presents this this notion of
jennifer walters just kind of holding on
to this last bastion it's the same way
things play out in their comics and it's
actually what made our comics really
interesting under dan's slot there will
likely come a time in the tv show when
the marvel cinematic universe will adapt
the stories from she-hulk where
basically jennifer walters stops being
jennifer walters and just stays the
she-hulk full-time that will likely
happen again her being in the mcu also
does present the possibility that at
some future point in time she can
replace ben grimm on the fantastic four
i'm sure that'll piss a lot of people
off but it'll be kind of interesting
because they'll be like that's
ridiculous right as a comic book fan
that does not need to happen and it'll
be like but it did though it did happen
in the comics you don't know that
because you don't know anything about
comics but it did happen in the comics
so it's gonna be one of those funny
moments i'm kind of curious to see how
that unfolds i will be frothing at the
mouth with a chance to make fun of those
guys but at the end of the day i do love
the show i think it's a phenomenal show
it's it's hilarious so far i'm
absolutely loving the whole thing and
i'm excited to see how it ends with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace